powerful and deadly Lake Effect
snowstorm is still pounding parts of the
Great Lakes area this morning including
Western New York dangerous snow squalls
have left parts of the Buffalo area
buried under five and a half feet of
snow travel all but impossible in those
areas winter storm and freeze warnings
are in effect for the region with the
snow expected to continue through
tomorrow in places Tanya Rivero is in
Buffalo
Tanya good morning
good morning Jeff more than a foot of
snow fell here in the Buffalo area
that's a historic record but that is
bringing snow totals in some parts as
you mentioned of the Buffalo area up to
five feet already this morning the
culmination of 36 hours of historic
blizzard conditions here in Western New
York multiple New York counties are
under a state of emergency the National
Guard is coming in today to help clear
those treacherous roads several travel
Bans are in effect including here in
Buffalo and officials are taking those
travel bans seriously they have issued
already over 300 tickets to drivers
ignoring the ban and often getting stuck
at least two deaths have been attributed
to cardiac events related to shoveling
this wet heavy snow that is also hanging
on tree branches and Downing power lines
thousands are without power this morning
as temperatures are expected to plummet
into the feel like teens and single
digits now this historic Lake Effect
storm is producing incredibly localized
conditions they vary significantly not
just from town to town but actually from
Street to street though there will be
periods of relative calm followed by
ferocious squalls that of course leave
residents guessing buffaloes snow-filled
football stadium shows clearly why
tomorrow's Buffalo Bills game against
the Cleveland Browns will now be played
in Detroit now the last time that
happened was eight years ago in this
area experienced another historic Lake
Effect storm that killed 14 people and
Stranded thousands of drivers Governor
hokel is expected to make her way to
Buffalo today the bills are also
expected to make their way out on their
way to Detroit however it remains to be
seen if anyone gets in or out of Buffalo
with the streets still impassable and
the Buffalo airport buried under a foot
of snow this morning and all flights
canceled
Jeff Tanya I got to tell you you know
Jeff's from there so you've done a
wonderful job and I do not want to make
light of the weather there I know it's
serious but next time I say we just send
Jeff and we don't make you stand up I
mean I'm happy to give Tanya great job
by the way yeah and but great point
about the localized effects because my
mom texted me and said Jeff you have to
correct for the record I'm in Tonawanda
we got one to two inches of snow crazy
at last reports and meanwhile Orchard
Park has you know five six feet so it
really all depends on where you are but
it getting colder it can be very yeah
and people do with Lake Effects no
understand in those areas how different
it could be